and there's zach wheeler heading out to
the mound getting set to start for the
fills wieners one and two on the way
swinging a miss blew him away fastball
outer third
and peterson down on strikes for out
number one establishing the fastball
early
we've seen how many times have we seen
it where guys throwing good fastball
then all of a sudden they want to start
throwing the breaking ball more two down
base is empty for freddie freeman
wheeler
freeman with a base hit to left that's
no surprise over to cut it off is andrew
mccutchen he'll send it in that'll leave
freddie freeman standing at first base
and it's a two out single out of freddy
austin reilly comes to the plate one on
two outs austin swings to the first
pissy seas and sends one down the right
field line this is a fair ball into the
corner freddie freeman making his way to
third base and they stop him right there
runs into a stop sign at third
and austin riley with a two out double
so the braves with back to back two out
knocks no scores we had to the bottom of
the first inning it'll be seguro muto
and harper for the phillies facing max
freed who's on the mound for the 16th
time this season i'd bring up j.t romuto
there you go a high fly ball to deep
left field that's a nice way to start
the first
a solo home run for jt rebutto
and the phillies are on top one nothing
here in the first
ten home runs for jt
jt takes a couple pitches
and look where he hits this ball tom
beautiful out in front here's catch and
the pitch
looper out to right peterson coming in
and he's not going to get there
harper had to hold up just to make sure
so a little single for mccutchen two
balls and a strike offering from wheeler
that's hitting the air out towards right
field down for a base hit cutting it off
now bryce harper
steven boat makes the turn at first base
throws on the brakes he's got himself a
lead off single
and a strike three call the little punch
out by the home plate up fire
second strikeout for wheeler one two
and a strike three called at the knees
98 miles an hour
he's got three strikeouts two looking
and now two outs for freed coming up
after seeing slider slider slider and
all of a sudden 98 down and away
swing it to miss he struck out three in
a row to finish up the second inning
after the lead off single by vote
4ks overall
middle of the second until he's on top
one to nothing wheeler 162 hitter for
the season altogether oh two pitch on
the way
got him looking strike three front door
slider bats with two down and a runner
at first base one nothing phillies in
the bottom of the second
and he came back to strike him out so
elite off walk but free does put up a
zero for atlanta it's a one-nothing
phillies game and the top of the order
coming up for the braves base is empty
one down for ozzy albee's
ozzy shoots one toward the gap in right
center harper can't get that that's
going to bounce off the base of the wall
and ozzie albee's has a one-out double
the fourth braves hit their second two
base hit of the game
and the tying run is in scoring position
joe girardi in some trouble you've got
the hottest hitter on the planet and
freddie freeman
little looper in the shallow left that's
going to get down for a hit here comes
ozzie around third he is going to score
and the braves have tied the game
freddie freeman two for two
it's a one-one game
fastball in
a pitch that's not easy to hit
gets jammed shoots it down the left
field line gets the job done
rbi situation freddie freeman comes
through
continues to absolutely rake
against zach wheeler
austin riley is the batter
goes again
swinging a miss throw to second base is
in time a strikeout throw out double
play
that was a very comfortable throw by jt
rio muto to get him
one one game into the bottom of the
third and jt romuto who is
responsible for the phillies run comes
to the plate to lead it off oh two pitch
curve ball swung on and missed good
sharp curve
something down
that's where he wants that pitch
line drive out to left field going back
on it is almonte it's over his head and
he's hard off the wall harper's gonna
try to get to second base the throw is
there in time and he's safe
all these he reached too high with the
tag it'll be a double for harper
frayed back in the count two balls two
strikes for andrew mccutchen
and he chased a breaking ball freed's
last four outs have been strikeouts
and now rhys hoskins is the hitter with
a runner at second and two outs swatson
vote in el monte
got him with a curve ball six strikeouts
for zach wheeler here's the 1-2 pitch
swing and a mess
pulling the dirt tagged by romuto
there's another strikeout for weiner oh
and two on thereas and free delivers in
the pitch swung on grounded to short
could be two swanson two albies there's
one on to first not in time ball got
away
and down to second goes to reyes
i think a clean slide by alec bowm there
at second but uh hobbies you think would
be charged with an error gene tonight is
over two against freed
pulls it off the third base bag down the
left field line to reyes will score
misplayed by almante williams can fly
he's going to score standing it's a
two-run double for gene segora
that ball was a couple inches off the
ground look at that i mean limit the
handout oh it's just amazing that's why
he's you know he's 300 hitter and why
he's at how many years of 200 hits i
mean this guy
he finds a way harper is walked and
doubled
line drive basic for harper to left
field
he sees freed well
that's his seventh hit
in 17 at bats against him 2-1 pitch
runner goes the pitch is taken low the
throw to second not in time and uh
almost got away from albies it did get
away just not far enough for harper to
advance in extra base
runner goes they've got hoskins and here
comes harper coming home albie's throw
is not in time harper scores standing
all these didn't put much on that throw
at all
stolen every base tonight except for
first the first time he's done that in
his career three so for two he's flat
out twice and he's walked
yeah baby reese it's the left field that
one's going to the wall real muto was
motored around third he's heading home
no throw by swanson 5-1 phillies rbi
double for reese 25th of the year
and the payoff
a high fly ball shallow center field oh
double is in he's under it makes the
catch and the ball game is over
the fields
play a much cleaner game tonight than
they did last night and they win it by a
final score of five to one
to even the series at one win a piece
[Music]
and maintain their spot
behind the bets but move a game ahead of
the atlanta braves in the national
league east